hey everybody what is going on you just
saw the announcement from sigma we've
had the lens in our hands for the past
couple weeks the all new sigma 150 to
600 f5 to 6.3
dgdn for the l mount alliance as well as
the e-mount now there is a separate
video for you sony users out there but
for those of you in the l mount alliance
like a panasonic sigma this video is for
you i've had the ability to try this
lens on two cameras the sigma fpl as
well as the leica sl2 big thanks to my
friend casey eng for allowing me to uh
use his sl2 for this review and of
course sigma singapore for providing the
lens and the fpl having said that we're
not paid or sponsored for this my
thoughts my thoughts only let's talk
about how this lens performs on the
l-mount cameras
[Music]
we're going down
a drop
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
the pu leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
all right so let's talk about what is
inside of this lens you have 25 elements
in 15 groups four fld elements two sld
elements the weight of this lens comes
in at 2100 grams or 74.1 ounces
the filter diameter on the front of this
is 95 millimeters and your minimal
focusing distance at 150 is 58
centimeters and that was 600 it is 280
centimeters so keep that in mind
actually it's pretty nice because if you
really want to get close up on something
for a super zoom like this
actually does a really good job
moving around the lens though you're
going to notice there are of all the
switches you need it has optical
stabilization inside of this you do have
your number two number one and off on
that your autofocus manual focus
switches you can adjust uh the range of
focus that it has from full 10 meters
etcetera etcetera then you have your
custom c2 c1 and off
the tripod ring is not removable but
you can actually turn it and actually
has stopping points throughout the range
so you can adjust it to your liking and
then you just lock it down
where you want it to stop this is an
arca swiss compatible uh tripod mount on
this so keep that in mind and you can
remove it for these four screws but
again you cannot remove the entire ring
you do have these programmable buttons
right here these function buttons so you
can adjust whatever settings you'd like
to that then you also have this new um
zoom torque switch to this so this is
new to the dg dm variant of this lens
because you have lock tension and smooth
basically lock course locks the zoom
tension makes it much more of a slower
zoom out and then smooth it makes it
fast action also this is a dual action
zoom and this is nice because you
actually can use pull you use your hand
just pull it out
or use the zoom ring so as you're going
to see we'll walk around the zoo here
i'll be taking photos a lot of the times
i'll be using this to adjust really
quickly versus using this ring and
turning around it just makes capturing
subjects a lot easier and a lot faster
but besides that this is splash and dust
resistant it has oil repellent coating
on the front of the lens this is a
really robust lens i mean this is a
sports lineup from sigma so
even from their previous versions from
the sports online from sigma we knew
that those lenses were built and
designed for professionals you're
getting that same quality in this dgdn a
variant on it except it's a little bit
more compact and it is l mount native to
this so anyway uh yeah it looks
beautiful here on the sl2 but let's take
it through its paces around the
singapore zoo zach are you ready yeah
let's do it
[Music]
all right so now using this lens on the
sigma fp um
this is gonna be a little bit
challenging in the sense because
this camera is not really designed for
sports it's an electronic shutter which
is fine in brighter conditions but in
terms of its speed and buffering it's
not at the level of let's say other
cameras so this is much more of a
lifestyle camera but i'm putting it on
here to try it out i'm image quality of
course out of the fpl is fantastic um 16
megapixels
beautiful colors coming out of the
signal sensor so i mean this is really
nice
it does help a bit more with the evf i
will tell you that because i try to use
the 100 or 400 with the sigma fp prior
without an evf and that was challenging
to say the least this does make it a lot
easier to use
but it is as you can see quite a small
camera
on
the 150 to 600 a little bit different
but uh still an enjoyable experience but
you just have to really dial in your
settings and really fine tune it because
the fpl in terms of how you set
everything up it does take a little bit
of a learning curve
i mean there's some nice shots but you
know what i mean there's three of them
too
also another thing if you're wondering
here on the sl2 and sl2s does recognize
the lens has all the information there
so that's gonna help with your except
data and i don't know if there's any
in-camera corrections happening
unfortunately because we're in this
shaded area and because it's a f5 to 6.3
at 600 millimeters at 6.3 i am about to
crank up the iso a little bit now that's
not the sl2's strongest
attribute but there is some dedicated
noise reduction software like topaz de
noise and other ones that will do an
admirable job of reducing that and a lot
of photographers use it nowadays
especially for wildlife because as you
can see sometimes you're not going to
have every animal in the optimal
lighting condition so
you work with it and you make it work
and there's a lot of beautiful shots out
there and just the images i'm getting
straight out of camera right now with
the sl2 i'm quite impressed
unfortunately the buffering on this
camera i mean this is not a camera
review but the buffering you know if
you're gonna be shooting at continuous
uh speeds it's gonna kick in so it's
something to take note of go in short
bursts but uh i mean it's tempting
because we have a lens like this you
just want to fire away you know what i
mean and just
not worry about the buffer but that's
not going to be the case with the sl2
and even with the sigma fp that i have
in my bag i'll show you that in just a
second you're going to have to face some
of those issues now this is where the
fpl works well as with
static animals
it performs well i mean honestly as i
mentioned before this is not a sports
camera we all know that
but
if you have an fp and fpl and you want
to you know get into something a little
bit more with a longer focal range
it does work
pretty good
just if you're going to chase cheetahs
or chase any fast animals
nada so with that let's go into
lightroom and let's take a look at
images from the leica sl2 and the sigma
fpl with
this sigma 150 to 600 f5 to 6.3 dg dn
all right guys we're now in lightroom
taking a look at images from the sigma
fpl and the leica sl2 with the sigma 150
to 605 to 6.3 dg dn lens now we're first
gonna take a look at images from the
sigma fpl now out of in terms of the l
mount alliance i love the fpl for its
color for its detail
i love how sigma just really produces
some beautiful images out of this camera
system now
with a 150 to 600 because the size of
this camera as i mentioned in the review
um it may not be the most optimal camera
for wildlife sports photography
or birding for that matter because of
the size because it's electronic shutter
only that lack of ibis i should say i
mean of course you have os inside the
lens but it does help when the camera
also has it so
it you can get some decent shots out of
it you just have to make sure that your
subject is still and you really have
your settings dialed in on the fpl but i
did i was able to get a couple shots
that i really liked out of uh my visit
to the zoo and i'll show you some of
those images real quick first off here
is um
kind of a profile shot of this lizard at
the zoo i believe it's a monitor lizard
i'm not too sure but it's a lizard
anyway let's look at this real quick
this is uh
pretty tack sharp i have to say not too
bad i'm doing everything handheld by the
way there's no tripod this is iso 250
600 millimeters of 6.3 one over three
twentieths of a second and yeah the
colors out of this are fantastic i love
the colors out of the sigma fpl it's
beautiful now i did slightly overexpose
this image you can see right here
actually really overexposed because i
should have uh you know had a higher
shutter speed on this my apologies on
that um i was going back and forth
between two cameras for this review but
because of the dynamic range
in the fpl i'm able to rescue a lot of
detail
and uh the highlights so hats off to
sigma for a fantastic uh sensor and
processor inside of this camera but
again look at this the detail fantastic
the fall off from the head where it's in
focus to the back area it looks really
really good let's look at another image
here real quick um this is of these
tortoises and i just thought this was
really cute they were just kind of
creeping on each other and then they
finally sort of you know put their heads
next to each other it was kind of like a
romantic moment between tortoises i had
no idea if they liked each other or not
but it was that image but uh look at
this really nice um it was sharp looked
good yes i'm at iso 1600 150 millimeter
in terms of focal length at 5.9 one over
one thousandths of a second
and uh this is before edit
and after edit
before edit and after edit so i was
bringing out some of the detail in the
shell area here and in terms of their uh
their skin but yeah i'm very very happy
with this and of course if you want to
use any sort of post-processing software
you can enhance the sharpening and
reduce the noise as well
okay
now let's move over to the leica sl2
because a lot of leica users out there
that are looking for a native l-mount
super zoom lens
this is gonna be the lens you're gonna
be shopping for the price point is
fantastic it's 150 to 600
you don't need to adapt anything like
you needed to do previously so you're
really going to get
really good at performance autofocus
works well
tracking works well again it works as
good as the camera does now i'll talk
about that throughout some of these
images here but um hopefully i mean
there's supposed to be an update to the
sl2 from what i understand it was
supposed to be the end of july that was
a rumor didn't happen maybe it'll happen
this week that the video is out who
knows but let's go back into the image
quality with this sigma lens on the sl2
now let's look at these white rhinoceros
here real quick and i want to show you
an image with uh really good lighting at
iso 640 355 millimeters at 5.9 one over
1 250th of a second and this is really
tack sharp here folks i mean i'm really
focusing on this area and you can see
the scaling the detail the wrinkles and
the skin it looks beautiful
nice separation from what's in focus to
the background here and the courses has
been edited slightly just slightly in
terms of exposure bringing down the
highlights a little bit and uh you know
this
the dynamic range in the sl2 is really
good and i'm happy with what i'm seeing
out of this especially at a lower iso
numbers
but let's talk about something a little
bit higher here's his meerkat here and i
was actually wanted to test this lens
against backlight because you know this
is where you really kind of stress test
the lens a little bit more in terms of
purple fringing green fringing or you
know how does it handle backlight and
this is pretty severe it was near top of
day and uh
you know these meerkats were walking out
of their little uh cubby hole area and i
was able to capture one of them this is
at iso 800 403 millimeters of six point
three one over five hundredths of a
second this has been edited slightly
this is before edit and here's after
edit before edit and after edit now
edits our personal preference you may
like or dislike how i edit the image but
uh i just want to kind of give you an
idea of what you can do with it i always
bring out the details and the highlights
in the fur area here but as we look at
the um the highlight area here you're
going to see a little bit of blue
fringing right there with the hair but
again this may be more to do with the
color of the hair than actually the lens
itself let's look at uh
before the edit here and yeah it does a
pretty decent job i mean you can
actually reduce this even more if i
wanted to but for a quick edit i'm very
very happy with this and if i want to
reduce the blue i can do that and post
no issues at all but uh again sharp
detailed
very very happy with what i'm seeing
here meerkats are fun to shoot because
they're very animated and when they
stand still they really stand still so
you can really lock on focus but look at
the detail in the eye and the fur area
right here it's fantastic and this is at
uh this is before edit
after edit before edit after it i just
did minor adjustments because i really
didn't need to do much because of the
great lighting conditions and the great
color coming out of the sl2
iso 640 600 millimeters of 6.3 one over
640 of a second
again tack sharp i love the fall off on
this um from what's in focus to the
background area it looks really really
good sigma is touting this uh as you
know a 600 prime or whatever focal
length you're at it's like it acts like
a prime lens and
while i don't have a prime uh 600
millimeter lens or 500 millimeter lens
or 400 to you know compare it to i can
say that i was very happy with the
performance right regardless if it's at
150 or at 600 in terms of how this lens
performed and let's just go over a
couple images here's a lion here
this was a little trickier because the
line was in the shade and uh you know i
was battling that shutter speed want to
get it in focus and of course iso this
is an iso 6400 600 millimeters of 6.3
one over four hundredths of a second and
we zoom in on this
tack sharp here in the eye area you are
going to see some noise creeping in
around here because of the uh
uh the lower light situation here again
this can be fixed in let's say topaz de
noise or another software whatever you
use i personally use topaz denoise i'm
not sponsored by them i paid for it out
of my own pocket but i'll show you the
end result here to give you an idea of
what you're able to achieve with this
software with uh you know a little bit
of editing to really fine-tune this
image even more but i'm again i'm happy
with it the colors out of this line look
fantastic here's uh before edit here's
after edit before edit and after edit
and uh
let me just show you one more image here
of this red panda very interesting
animal very very cute but they move
around quite fast when they want to move
and i was able to capture one shot in
focus here you are gonna see some noise
creeping in here because i was trying to
push the shadows up a little bit more as
you can see
this was the original shot
and then here's my edit again run this
through some noise reduction software it
does clean up quite nicely but i love
the fall off from the fur that's in
focus to the background area it's really
really nice so again very happy with
this was this was shot at 395
millimeters iso 6400 f 6.3 one over one
thousandths of a second the reason i was
cranking up my shutter speed a little
bit more on this is because i wanted to
make sure that the animal was sharp um
because you know they move around quite
fast and you know i don't want to push
the iso up even more if i want to go up
to like 8 000 or 10 000 i don't have to
worry about it so much but i wanted to
keep it low so i could get a cleaner
image so overall i mean you've seen some
images throughout this review the lens
performs quite well on the sl2 and the
sigma fpl again iso will be something
that you might have to deal with with
the sl2 but if you want to see how a
more modern sensor renders these uh
renders the sigma 150 to 600 you can
check out my sony e-mount review with
the uh the alpha one so you can see a
little bit of a difference there but i'm
happy with this and for sl2 users out
there sl2s users out there
lumix s1r s1 s1h s5
you know you've finally got yourself a
native superzoom lens that's going to
produce some beautiful images at a very
attractive price point anyway enough of
me talking here let's go to my final
thoughts on the lens so my final
thoughts on this lens for the l mount
alliance i mean
there is no other option out there
that's a native l mount lens at this
vocal range out there i mean from 150 to
600 this is a fantastic lens it's sharp
it has great uh rendition i mean we saw
all the images in lightroom and
throughout this review it performs
beautifully on the sl2 and even here on
the sigma fpl now
this camera i like this camera a lot
image quality is fantastic sigma's
colors are great but it's not really
designed to take advantage of a lens
like this you need a camera that has
mechanical and electronic shutter that
has more of those classic ergonomics to
really help you you know balance this
lens and shoot with it of course um if
you're going to shoot still subjects the
fpl is fine but if you're going to be in
let's say you're going to do sporting
events in artificial lighting situations
because this is only an electronic
shutter here you might face some banding
issues or may face some odd rolling
shutters so that you don't want to
experience that so i would recommend it
problems possibly with the sl2 sl2s
lumix s1rs1 s1hs5
you know the drill but uh i'm a big fan
of this lens and especially for the
price point
this is an amazing bargain um
sigma i wasn't expecting them to come at
this price point i thought it was going
to be in the mid 2000s uh singapore
dollars but they have surprised me
coming in under 2 000 singapore dollars
for this lens um yeah it's a great
performer i highly recommend it so those
are my thoughts on the all-new sigma 150
to 600 f5 to 6.3 dg dn lens for the l
mount let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below is the lens you're
going to pick up are you going to pass
on it i want to hear from you guys
anyway like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us here on this channel
like this video it helps us out a lot
stay safe take care and i'll chat you
soon
[Music]